we continue our trip to Southern
California thanks to the sponsors of
this segment visit Anaheim Jillian takes
us inside the house of the Retro Future
theme Suite over at the Howard Johnson
Anaheim
welcome to the Future The House of the
Retro future that is we are here at the
Howard Johnson in Anaheim and I cannot
wait to show you around this Suite but I
need a little help getting a tour so I'm
joined by the general manager Jonathan
thank you so much for having us you're
welcome I feel like I am transported in
time when I come through the doors tell
us a little bit about the inspiration of
The Suite well the suite was inspired by
the original Monsanto House of the
future that was featured at Disneyland
in the 50s and 60s so we tried to
recreate that that feeling that uh that
style with the suite yeah and you guys
do not spare any thing from the the
curved couches to the pillows to the
table to the chairs everything is really
well thought out right yep and something
that I am eyeing over here this is maybe
my favorite part of the room you have a
real record player yes and with real
finals under there real uh curated
selection of uh uh period appropriate
music yes I love it it really sets the
vibe while you're in the room and also I
cannot stop looking at the artwork on
the wall tell us about that it's shag so
uh the artist Josh eagle or better known
as shag and uh he created this artwork
and it's a family in the house of the
future featured in this house of the
future Suite oh my gosh all right let's
keep walking because there's more to see
throughout our tour in this week tell us
about this room in here obviously it's
the it's the bedroom and attaches the
bathroom so we took some Liberties in
the bedroom because we we saw that the
original House of the future was not
really designed for a family as a hotel
so we wanted to really just create that
that feeling of the mid-century style
and the googie architecture of the 60s
and so this is what we came up with well
and speaking of families you guys are
truly right across the street from
Disneyland you can walk right over this
is a great place for families to stay
and in addition to this really cool
Suite you also have a variety of rooms
some of which have been renovated right
so a little something for everyone and
those rooms are great for families
they're large rooms and they also have
this kind of mid-century vibe to them
well I think what anyone sees this room
they're going to want to stay here and I
have been eyeing you even have an orange
phone back there and that's authentic
right it is authentic yeah how of fun is
it for you to have this themed Suite
here and what are people saying about it
so far it's been a lot of fun and people
just that have stayed or visited when
they walk in the room and you just see
that that feeling that comes over them
that they've transported themselves to
uh that earlier time that's just really
neat it's so much fun I love seeing
every little thing throughout the
Ruth room there's some
there's not going to tell you exactly
what it is because you got to come here
to see it for yourself the lights around
every corner oh I love that well
Jonathan thank you so much for giving us
this tour this Suite is so cool you
definitely want to check it out and I
think it's time I think we got to crank
up that record player what do you say
let's go check it out time to play some
tunes Jonathan thank you so much
that room is awesome now is your chance
yeah here's your chance to win a
two-night stay at the JW Marriott
Anaheim Resort tickets you also get
tickets to a hockey game at the Honda
Center and a four pack of tickets to
Knott's Berry Farm just go to
8newsnow.com and enter today's keyword
getaway